le retour des touristes mont saint
michel doucement mais sûrement
depuis lundi les portes de ce site
exceptionnel sont de nouveau ouvertes
après 55 jours de confinement inquiets
depuis à plus de deux mois pour la
survie de leur entreprise
le retour des visiteurs l annonce du
premier ministre en faveur d'un plan
massif pour venir en aide au secteur est
un véritable soulagement pour les
acteurs économiques du monde la
possibilité à cette échéance du mois de
juin alors le deux roues a peu après
d'envisager la réouverture en zone verte
des cafés et des restaurants
parce que c'est un élément très
important
le mont saint michel est un lieu où on
vient aisément passer la journée et
souvent même quelques jours donc
l'absence d'activités de restauration
même si les hôtels pourrait ouvrir ce
qui n'est pas le cas mais l'absence de
restauration est très dommageable de moi
donc que les touristes n'avaient pas
foulé les pavés d'un des sites les plus
visités de france pour les commerçants
et restaurateurs le temps a semblé bien
long
certains auraient même perdu jusqu'à un
tiers de leur chiffre d'affaires annuel
si tous les commerces n'ont pas ouvert
leurs portes certains ont tenu tout de
même à être présent pour les visiteurs
je vais pas vous dire non ça nous
inquiète et c'est sûr façon là c'est
deux mois qu'ils sont très gros parce
qu'il y avait les vacances en avril et
au mois de mai tous les ponts c est le
temps superbe a donc logiquement il y
aurait dû avoir beaucoup beaucoup de
monde le mont saint michel qui peut
parfois accueillir plus de 20000
personnes quotidiennement semble donc
bien vide en cette belle journée du mois
de mai
l'abbaye demeure fermée au public encore
quelques semaines les visiteurs
priviligié viennent d'un rayon de moins
de 100 km conformément aux mesures
sanitaires à des touristes pas si
malheureux de flâner peu nombreux dans
ce décor majestueux vite ça fait un peu
triste
démocratiques qui sont pas ouvertes mais
c'est agréable pour se pendre mais par
contre c'est vrai que le fait de
d'être ici aujourd'hui ça permet de
mieux profiter la visible parce que on
est moins bousculés on a on a plus d'
approche à tous c'est vrai que c'est
dommage pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas
être là non plus c'est un petit peu
tristounet quand même mais on aime bien
quand même qu'ils aient un peu de foule
quand même puis pour trouver les
commerçants qui ont quand même perdu pas
mal d'argent ont trouvé faire
sa part quand est-ce qu'ils vont rouvrir
c'est un peu d'entre eux pour tout le
monde ça permet d'apprécier le mois le
moins de monde loin de nous de prendre
le temps de prendre le temps d'apprécier
le paysage coin de mais c'est vrai que
c'est superbe
et pour faire respecter les mesures
sanitaires un sens de circulation a été
mise en place au monde tout s'organise
donc pour un retour progressif à la
normale est espéré pour le 2 juin
prochain
[Musique]